[Music]
no want me go to these stupid parties
there's my ham you guys someday our kids
are gonna be together let go of that
seat ponytail right now hello
hey sue psych for your Bachelorette
weekend job run it we are peaceful
protesters okay I gotta head to a batch
mommy we have two remaining I really do
oh yeah we're not your pork go go get
out of here I called the room next to
Jett you're gonna have to share with
Pippa uh who dad about my Australian
friends semester abroad oh my god yeah
vacuum I'm ready to get active yeah I'm
here and I'm ready to attack this
weekend's all about us just like old
times
what's next just went really fast
how are you alive right now like toys
north
oh he's dead
ah okay they got me on everything all
right
[Applause]
[Music]
the truck
[Music]
I know that things are crazy right now
but you're gonna have a lot of material
for my wedding speeches I had this
nightmare where we had all killed a guy
what no oh my god jet lag is insane you
guys it's no joke no joke
[Music]
you